[Music]
well back to the Golden Globes this
morning they rolled out the red carpet
and that is usually well a state a
little boring to watch but not with host
Jimmy Fallon on hand who totally took
over the ceremony their ceremony only
took eight seconds but Jimmy made the
most of it now i'm gonna kick from this
side he did three takes and then
practice his red carpet walk
[Applause]
the press loved it and he obviously
loved the press I had to make love to
the camera what'd they say Hollywood
Foreign Press you must make love to the
camera and that's what I do welcome you
bunch of Despicable spoiled minimally
talented brats of course previous hosts
have made mincemeat of stars in the
audience you gusting pill-popping sexual
deviants come when she one of these
celebrities should be worried no one has
to be worried with me no one we have a
fun surprise pre-taped opening that is
cameo after kavitha can be so good so
good I won't say any one things ryan
reynold oh man i just want you to see it
that's all I'm just excited I want you
to see it thank you guys so much i
appreciated thank you for coming out
[Music]